imagine you order food for dinner but
then the delivery biker is late
5 10 maybe even 15 minutes
so you start wondering did he have an
accident
does he have any social protection at
all any social rights
in this third episode of what's left we
will explore how the european union is
finally willing to deliver
on its social promises
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
19th century the industrial revolution
new industries new sources of energy new
means of transport
the world gets smaller the rich get
richer while workers are being exploited
workers start fighting back sometimes
paying with their own lives
they get organized to fight for their
rights the right to form unions
the right to strike paid leave the
five-day working week
the eight-hour working day gender rights
okay let's do so workers form
movements trade unions and they find
their allies in the social democratic
family
they took the streets but later on their
fight was
also taken to the parliaments now with
the
industrial changes again it's again
necessary
to unite to form alliances
and also be the ally of the workers
bring proposals of the workers to the
table
if we let everything happen as it goes
and you say it's all a free market
it's clear who's paying the price and
that are the ordinary workers
but what is happening today in 2021
today we are once again living in
revolutionary times
turning our society our economy and our
culture
upside down the social fights of today
are very different than the ones that
were led in the past
centuries today we live in a much more
digital world and we have to deal with
climate change
these two realities should not unfold at
the expense of people
that is why everybody needs to be
socially protected
there is a risk that the digital
transformation increases
inequality social exclusion poverty
it may degrade labor market conditions
and job
opportunities and we know that there is
a digital
gender gap that needs to be tackled the
digital and green transitions
are central when building a more
resilient and sustainable european union
but this transition won't be a success
if it's not made in a socially
positive manner that leaves no one
behind
the european green deal is the eu
solution to these challenges
the idea is to transform our system in
order to win the fight against climate
change
but how will this affect us
we have about a decade that's what
scientists tell us
to change dramatically or our planet
will not be
capable to cope with the rhythm in which
we are consuming the resources so the
way we are using
fresh water the way we are fishing the
way we are eating and obviously the way
we are using fossil fuels to basically
sustain almost our all of our way of
living so that has to change that is why
we want
not just to use more renewable energy
but to consume less energy
to change the way we transport goods or
people around the world
at the same time we understand fully
that it's not just about going into this
direction of greening of the
carbonization but it's also taking in
account
the consequences on people's lives on
workers lives on their jobs
we need to put a red heart a social
dimension into the green deal
with concrete policies training people
so that they can get the new jobs the
new opportunities that will come
the social ecological crisis is already
happening
inequalities are rising at rocket speed
the world's richest one percent
have more than twice as much wealth as
6.9 billion people
and our planet is in danger we need to
limit global warming by at least 2
degrees celsius by 2050
so we need to change the economy and
that's what the european green deal is
all about
but that leaves a few questions hanging
will workers have to change sectors
and if so will they be retrained will we
lose jobs as a result of
artificial intelligence and robots
what role is there for social security
schemes in this digital world
the reality of today is quite different
than it was in the 19th century
so the question is has the european
union done anything
to protect social rights
crisis
[Music]
for instance let's say let's get rid of
the youth unemployment
in the next 10 years let's end the
difference in pay between men
and women i think our fight should be
the fight for
social targets mandatory and
legally enforceable social rights touch
on many different aspects
for example youth unemployment or
teleworking and the right to disconnect
or gender pay gap the fact that men and
women are still not paid the same for
the same job
people who regularly work from home
are twice as likely to work more than
the
maximum stipulated working hours workers
deserve
the right to disconnect for us the youth
guarantee is an important instrument to
guarantee
social rights for young people now it
needs to be stronger
with more money it needs to get to those
young people that are mostly need
and especially we need to be very hard
on
unpaid internships we want to ban and
fed internships
since the beginning of the copy 19
pandemic women have been hit harder
as in all crises women's economical
situations
risk being harder hit in the long term
this is a battle we have to fight on
many fronts
for women and for gender equality social
rights have a deep impact on what our
lives
look like but today we are facing
unprecedented changes
how can people continue to be protected
when the world is moving so fast
in the beginning of this episode i told
the story of a delivery biker
how can we protect him i think it's
very clear that we can help him with one
solution
and that's our snd goal and that's
called
a reversal of the burden of proof
reversing the burden of proof means
assuming that the employment
relationship
between worker and digital platform
provides a full social and workers
rights
and it is up to the platforms to
demonstrate if that's not the case
because they say flexibility
entrepreneurship
extra income but what it comes down to
is a modern form of slavery
if uber drivers do not get any customers
they are stuck with the bill for the gas
if the livery bikers have an accident
they will be without sickbay
some of the richest companies on this
planet outsource their business risk
onto the workers and onto the taxpayers
to change the game of the gig economy
all platform workers must be considered
as employees
you have this huge transition towards
the carbonization towards the green
society
but at the same time to a digital
society we want a fair recovery
that means that those that are polluting
have to pay for this recovery those that
are the big companies that have avoided
to pay taxes in the past because they
use the loopholes in this in that
country
they will have to pay also for this
recovery and if we get those resources
and we direct them
towards this transition and towards the
the low-income families the low-income
households
then we are also creating a fairer
society
[Music]
the porto social summit on the 7th of
may 2021
will provide an opportunity for heads of
state ngos
unions and civil society to put social
rights back on top of the eu's agenda